frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen am vergangenen sonntagabend
konnten wir uns mit den
koalitionsfraktionen auch die
einzelheiten einer grundgesetzänderung
zur errichtung einer sondervorstellung
mit dem die ausrüstung und die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr
zusätzlich mit 100 milliarden euro
ausgestattet werden dieser sonntag war
und ist zuallererst ein guter tag für
die bündnisse und verteidigungsfähigkeit
des landes und ist ein guter tag für die
bundeswehr
ich will an dieser stelle hat sich dank
sagen an diejenigen die auf unserer
seite der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
die gespräche mit den
koalitionsfraktionen geführt haben also
kollegen alexander dobrindt mathias
middelberg zur wadephul und florian hahn
herzlichen dank dafür dass sie die
verhandlungen zielorientiert und
konstruktiv in unser aller namen geführt
haben
ebenfalls ein dank sagen an die
koalitionsfraktionen
dass sie bereit waren unseren wünschen
vollumfänglich zu folgen was die
ausgestaltung dieses sondervermögen
naja also wenn sie sie sind unsere
größten vollumfänglich nachgekommen und
ich will das noch mal kurz referieren
die 100 milliarden werden nur für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt es
wird einen wirtschaftsplan geben in dem
alle vorhaben aufgelistet werden die
die bundeswehr wird erstmalig in ihrer
geschichte einen
finanzierungsgesetz bekommen indem
klargestellt wird dass deutschland auch
nach der erschöpfung dieser 100
milliarden euro alle verpflichtungen
gegenüber der nato auch in zukunft
einhalten wird und das können auch mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes sein meine damen
und herren das ein guter vorschlag
es wird darüber hinaus bis zur
sommerpause unter bundeskanzler da sehen
wir sie in der pflicht das wirklich auch
einzuhalten was ihre verhandlungsführer
zugesagt haben einen vorschlag zur
reform des beschaffungswesens geben den
sehen wir als notwendig und als
dringlich an es wird schließlich eine
beteiligung des haushaltsausschusses mit
einem unterausschuss geben an der
einzelnen finanzierung bundes wird
abschließend der bundesfinanzminister
einen tilgungsplan geben den sie
ebenfalls zugesagt haben besser hätten
wir es nicht zu einem abschluss
gemeinsam bringen können herzlichen dank
nochmal auch an ihre adresse weinbar mit
hätten wir uns gewünscht dass auch im
hinblick auf die unmittelbare
herausforderung
der wir in diesen tagen und wochen
gestellt sind nämlich der eindämmung des
krieges in der ukraine
ähnlich klare und eindeutige politische
entscheidungen in deutschland
getroffen worden wären werten zu allen
gewünscht meine damen und herren dass
die bundesregierung den wunsch und dem
auftrag des deutschen bundestages
nachgekommen wäre den wir wenn auch herr
bundeskanzler in ihrer abwesenheit am 28
april ebenfalls in großer
übereinstimmung wie im deutschen
bundestag in einem entschließungsantrag
formuliert haben wir haben zur
erinnerung unter anderem beschlossen
neben der humanitären und finanziellen
hilfe der ukraine auch schwere waffen zu
liefern damit dieses land sich gegen die
russische aggression ausreichend und
erfolgreich verteidigen kann
so haben
muss ich feststellen mehr als einen
monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht geliefert
worden mehr als einem monat statt dessen
werden von mitgliedern ihrer
bundesregierung herr bundeskanzler und
aus ihrer partei heraus ständig
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
die schlicht und einfach falsch sind so
wird von einer parlamentarischen
staatssekretärin aus dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium behauptet
es gebe da eine nato vereinbarung dass
es keine schweren waffen
gelte für die ukraine ihre
parteivorsitzende bundeskanzler sagt
auch andere länder würden keine schweren
waffen liefern sei zwar keine formale
vereinbarung aber so eine art informelle
vereinbarung dass diese waffen nicht
geliefert werden und sie herr
bundeskanzler reden in letzter zeit
etwas mehr als sonst aber sie sagen
unverändert nichts was ist ein meine
gene muster aus dieser koalition
werthmann sich um unter den staats und
regierungschefs den abgeordneten in der
europäischen union dann kann ich
feststellen über die haltung der
bundesregierung gibt es mittlerweile nur
noch verstimmungen vorsichtig formuliert
es gibt enttäuschungen über die unklare
rolle deutschlands und es gibt richtig
verärgerung über sie und ihre regierung
und nicht nur während die opposition
sondern abgeordnete aus ihren reihen
herr bundeskanzler machen ihrem ärger
und ihrem unmut über das was hier in den
letzten tagen und wochen geschieht immer
lauter luft bis hin zu der wortmeldung
einer europaabgeordneten der kollegin
viola von cramon von den grünen die in
der letzten woche gesagt hat sie
brüsteten sich damit was man bereits für
die ukraine schon alles geleistet habe
sie würden dabei auf absprachen
verweisen mit vermeintlichen partnern
die es überhaupt nicht gebe ohne die
hilfe der usa sei die ukraine längst von
russland überrollt worden
abschließendes zitat für deutschland
bleibt jetzt nur noch verachtung übrig
ja das ist nicht aus unseren reihen
bundesland sein das kommt aus ihren
reihen aus den reihen ihrer kräfte
und am montag dieser woche titelte die
faz
chance ruiniert das ansehen der
deutschen politik
wörtliches zitat intext olaf scholz hat
immer wieder auf seinen amtseid
hingewiesen schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
den schaden den er gerade nicht abwendet
liegt im ansehensverlust der deutschen
politik
reflektion und vorsicht so schreibt
einer der herausgeber der faz
reflektion um vorsicht geld nicht ohne
grund als tugenden sie als fassade für
zaudern zu verwenden ist unredlich
unredlich so eine auszeichnung durch
eine große deutsche tageszeitung muss
man sich erstmal verdienen
unredlich steht als synonym für
böswillig verschweigen und aufrichtig
und ehrlich wer meine damen und herren
was verschweigen sie uns eigentlich herr
bundeskanzler
sie telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem
amarok mit dem russischen
staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der parlamentspräsident
der ukraine nach deutschland nach berlin
und sie verweigern ihm bis zu dieser
minute einen gesprächstermin
herr bundeskanzler was ist da eigentlich
los in ihrer regierung ich kann begrenzt
verstehen dass sie nicht nach kiew
reisen wollen aber wenn der
parlamentspräsident der zweithöchste
repräsentant der ukraine morgen in
berlin ist warum geben sie dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine keinen
gesprächstermin was ist da
und was soll das
was heißt das wenn sie sagen russland
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
das heißt das wenn sie sagen die ukraine
muss fortbestehen warum sagen sie nicht
einfach und ganz klar die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen
[Applaus]
warum sagen sie es nicht ganz klar
russland muss zumindest hinter die
kontakt linie vom 24 februar 2022
zurückgedrängt werden
kurzum regierung schlecht auf der welt
unten in europa es sagen es ist auch
nicht meine oder unsere frage allein
gibt es da mittlerweile eine zweite
agenda warum widerspricht aus ihren
reihen der spd niemand ihrem
amtsvorgänger im amt des bürgermeisters
der freien und hansestadt hamburg klaus
von dohnanyi der hier in diesen tagen
durch berlin von einer talkshow in die
andere geht russland in schutz nimmt
putin verteidigt und fast ausschließlich
den vereinigten staaten von amerika die
schuld an diesem krieg zubeißt herr
bundeskanzler was machen sie da und
warum stellen sie das nicht klar was sie
für eine meinung
sie haben am 27 februar von dieser
stelle aus eine vielbeachtete
regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im deutschen bundestag sehr viel
zustimmung bekommen
stehenden applaus auch von meiner
fraktion
ja das haben wir wohl zur kenntnis
genommen haben meine damen und herren
aber sie bleiben doch hinter den selbst
gestellten ansprüchen dieses 27 februar
mittlerweile tag für tag immer weiter
zurück sie haben an diesem tag klartext
gesprochen
sie haben an diesem tag gesagt die sieht
die lage sehen seit dem fall dampft und
verdunstet das alles was sie da gesagt
haben im unklaren im ungefähren und es
wird keine konkrete entscheidung
getroffen und hier begründet die an
dieses niveau und in diesem level
anschließen sie am 27 februar 2022 ihr
selbst gesetzt hatte
ich will einen zweiten aspekt hinzu
fügen wir sind ja nicht allein auf
dieser welt aber warum gibt es
eigentlich warum gibt es eigentlich von
ihrer regierung herr bundeskanzler auch
von ihnen persönlich keine einzige
europäische initiative zum beispiel
zusammen mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten wie man in einer
solchen historischen situation jetzt
europa voran bringt und mit anderen
mitgliedstaaten zusammen auch in der
europäischen politik klar zeigt in
welche richtung jetzt europa entwickelt
werden soll und welche chancen europa
auch in diesem konflikt sieht für die
eigene bessere integration in der außen-
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
ich würde es mal so sagen haben sie
eigentlich außer der
formalen rhetorik irgendeinen vorschlag
wie sich europa in dieser historischen
phase des umbruchs aufstellen und
dauerhaft auch verteidigen kann gibt es
irgendeinen vorschlag aus ihrer
regierung
sie wenigstens teile des geld ist dass
wir jetzt in diesem sondervermögen
bereitstellen wollen in eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur ein die es uns
erlaubt schritt für schritt hin zu einer
europäischen außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik zu kommen und in
diesem zusammenhang wie wird eigentlich
die bundesregierung wie werden sie herr
bundeskanzler votieren wenn in wenigen
tagen der nächste europäische rat
stattfindet und auf der tagesordnung
steht die frage ob der ukraine moldau
und ob den westbalkanstaaten der
beitritt status der kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union gegeben wird herr
bundeskanzler das können sie doch nicht
der eu kommission überlassen das
irgendwie formal vorzubereiten das ist
doch eine zutiefst politische
entscheidung in der auch
[Applaus]
wenn sie es offen lassen wenn die größte
nation der europäischen union in dieser
frage unklar bleibt und keine klare
antwort gibt dann bleibt es in ganz
europa unklar und dann wird es in ganz
europa keine antwort geben also bitte
sagen sie was sie von dieser frage
halten und wie sie das sehen die
westbalkanstaaten moldau und die ukraine
sollen sie den kandidaten status
bekommen oder nicht
oder aber setzen sie das ford mit ihrer
politik was sie als finanzminister schon
in den letzten jahren ihrer regierung
getan haben nämlich praktisch jedes geld
jedes problem einfach nur mit neuem geld
zuzuschütten und ansonsten politischen
entscheidungen aus dem wege zu gehen
doch noch in dem zusammenhang mit dem
bundeshaushalt 2022 stellen sind ihnen
eigentlich die risiken bewusst mit denen
sie diesen bundeshaushalt in dieser
woche hier verabschiedet und zwar auch
ganz unabhängig von dem neuen schulden
die jetzt mit diesem sondervermögen
gemacht werden es könnte doch sein der
bundeskanzler dass sie schon in wenigen
wochen 60 milliarden euro für den klima-
und energiefonds gar nicht zur verfügung
haben weil ihnen das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht erlaubt
diese mittel aus dem chor ohne hilfen
aus dem kohlehilfen
zweckentfremden für die entscheidungen
ihrer regierung die eigentlich aus dem
haushalt finanziert werden müssen
es könnte sein dass könnte sein dass sie
jahr für jahr zehn milliarden euro
zurückzahlen müssen an diejenigen die
einkommensteuer und körperschaftsteuer
zahlen weil es an ihnen gescheitert ist
den solidaritätszuschlag in der letzten
wahlperiode vollständig abzuschaffen das
ist ein jährliches fließen
ins team zusammen haben wenn sie damals
nicht aus ideologischen gründen sich
geweigert hätten den sony ganz
abzuschaffen sie hätten heute mit diesem
instrument das sie ihm selbst
diskreditiert haben sie hätten heute mit
diesem instrument ein instrument zur
verfügung mit dem wir wahrscheinlich die
neuen schulden für das sondervermögen
wurden es wäre gar nicht hätten
aufnehmen müssen sie hätten uns nämlich
den vorschlag machen können der
bundeskanzler dass wir einen solchen
solidaritätszuschlag auf die
einkommensteuer und auf die
körperschaftssteuer für die bundeswehr
dann wäre das vom heutigen generationen
bezahlt worden was eigentlich aufgabe
der heutigen generation bietet und nicht
die junge der redaktion
jahren und jahrzehnten mühsam
mühsam abziehen und in dem zusammen was
sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation was sagen ja dass dabei um
wobei ihnen auf punkt das kann ich gut
verstehen meine damen und herren bei
[Musik]
dem motto nimm glänzen ihre augen möchte
das hätten sie gerne aber sie können ihn
nicht einführen weil sie dieses
instrument einfach mutwillig zerstört
was sagen sie eigentlich ein
bundeskanzler der jungen generation dass
sie es erneut versäumt auch mit diesem
bundeshaushalt eine reform der renten
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation
[Musik]
was sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation dass sie es erneut versäumt
eine reform der rentenversicherung
vorzulegen die einerseits den
bundeszuschuss begrenzt und andererseits
der jungen generation eine sichere hat
das versorgung ermöglicht auch hier eine
zahl sie steuert
es gibt ich kann das kann das gut
verstehen
das ist nicht nur da sondern auch da auf
der regierungsbank gehörige unruhe gibt
sie müssen und sie müssen sie müssen
mehr als 100 milliarden euro
an zuschuss in die rentenversicherung
zahlen es gibt bis heute kein vorschlag
aus der koalition diese wetten
versicherung zu reformieren der letzte
reformvorschlag ist an ihnen gescheitert
und an ihnen der bundeskanzler in der
letzten koalition
hier hätten wir längst anderer form
machen müssen die ist nach ihnen
gescheitert sie haben ihre zustimmung
verweigert sie gegen reformvorschlag der
gemacht worden ist und so bleibt heute
festzustellen das wort zeitenwende dass
sie am 27 februar
2022 geprägt und verwendet haben dieses
wort zeitenwende bleibt außer neuen
schulden für dieses sondervermögen mehr
oder weniger beziehungslos im raum
stehen es gibt nichts was sie außer
neuen schulden mit diesem wort
zeitenwende zeitenwende ernsthaft
erwägen alles
[Musik]
so schön bleiben wie sie es in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag der mittlerweile nur
noch ins archiv gehört wie sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben im
gegenteil aus ihren reihen kommen fast
im wochenrhythmus neue vorschläge wie
man zusätzliches geld ausgibt der
jüngste vorschlag ihres sozialministers
ein soziales klima geld für einkommen
bis 8000 euro
konnten sich die reihen dieser koalition
an bei diesem wort soziales klima gehen
welche reaktionen dass hier im hause
auslöst
das ist so ganz
die linkspartei noch ein bisschen bleibt
aber trotz krise bei mehr für dieses
thema sie machen solche vorschläge hier
und ohne jede finanzierung einfach
zusätzliche neue schulden das ist die
botschaft dieser regierung und ist ganz
nah ich möchte in einen vorschlag machen
zum abschluss meiner rede sie haben
vermutlich eine vorformulierte
ausformulierte wege des
bundeskanzleramtes mitgebracht heute
morgen legen sie doch mal auf die seite
und beantworten sie bitte wenn es ihnen
möglich ist drei sehr konkrete fragen
die erste frage ist welche waffen
liefert die bundesrepublik deutschland
wirklich an die ukraine welche waffen
sollen sie liefern was ist ihre präzise
antwort auf diese frage zweitens
zweitens der bundeskanzler wie werden
sie europäischen rat abstimmen wenn die
frage beantwortet werden muss gibt es
für die ukraine und andere staaten den
beitritt status den kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union und dritte frage
und auch die wichtigste heute morgen
abweichend vom vorgetragenen
vorgelesenen redemanuskript ihr zu
beantworten welche vorschläge machen sie
zur reform der deutschen
rentenversicherung damit die junge
generation in diesem land eine
perspektive
anna gesicherten altersversorgung ich
finde hier in deutschland anstecken
in einer debatte über den etat des toten
sie ganz dass diese taten verantworten